it's a new week and that means new
releases and this week Formula one fans
get a hot racing game during the sparse
month of July where there's no actual
races between the British Grand Prix
which is on July fifth and the Hungarian
Grand Prix which is on july twenty sixth
but why watch when you can play f1 will
feature teams and driver lineups from
the 2015 season as well as drivers cars
and circuits from the 2014 season as
bonus content now the game officially
launches on the tenth of July but that's
for Europe North America will have to
wait until the 21st to get behind the
wheel smite comes into open beta on Xbox
one this week offering a free to play
mobile with third-person combat and a
first person shooter feel auto attacks
are skill shots and there are unique
death matches and themed games for game
mode variety so it's separating itself a
little bit similarly to the competition
it's five versus five deities as you
pick from a variety of self proclaimed
God's five which are free and rotations
and others that need to be unlocked with
gems you can purchase or favor you can
earn by playing become an open beta God
on the 8th
also this week we get a tactical squad
based shooter that allows for up to
eight people working cooperatively
together to shoot sci-fi stuff on Mars
as you venture forth fighting the
terrifying creatures that Iron Ward
studio has created from the deep
recesses of their nightmares you'll be
assuming the role of one of eight
different classes classes give you
unique abilities like the assault class
that has a wide range of weapons and is
pretty much average at everything or the
heavy class which tends to be a bit
slower but with way radder guns it comes
out of early access and into official
release on the 9th if you have a ps4
then you might have missed Numa breath
of life that was released on xbox one
and pc earlier but worry not because
this mind-bending first-person puzzler
has gone under the radar for most of its
release and that means it's remained
fairly spoiler-free the gorgeous open
world is filled with challenging
philosophical puzzles to bend your brain
and make you lose track of time you play
as God Numa and listen to your own inner
monologue of comical self-obsessed
thoughts while interacting with the
environment light humor mixed with
frustratingly difficult puzzles and a
beautiful environment means an easy
decision if you haven't tried it before
it's out on PSN on the 7th also this
week we get a frenetic fighting game
that's got tons of personality with
Skullgirls encore the 2d fighting game
was originally released in 2012 for ps3
with eight characters but now there
boasting 14 characters like this
ridiculous saxophone Inspector Gadget
it's releasing on ps4 and eventually
Vita it's a solid fighting game
encompassed by really sick and unique
animations so if you're a fighting fan
there will be crossed by for ps4 and
Vita and that makes it worth a look
check it out on the 7th
finally FIFA gets a much needed
improvement by battle cars with rocket
League a mix of soccer and rocket
powered cars set in a live frantic
stadium you might be thinking well I've
heard of a game like that before but it
was called supersonic acrobatic
rocket-powered battle cars and you're
right but the developer smartly decided
that the name was a bit ridiculous and
not in the good way so they changed it
to the really simple and easy to
remember rocket League it rolls up the
tongue barrel roll locally or online
with cross-platform play so ps4 players
can battle together with PC players for
the ultimate joy of hitting giant falls
with a rocket power car to score goals
whoo rocket League is out on the 7th for
further details visit gamespot com
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week